we Alzheimer Society here every day that
about the challenges that are facing
families affected by Alzheimer's disease
and so we know treatment news like this
is incredibly significant to those
families
um this is the first drug we've ever
seen to Target as you describe the root
cause of Alzheimer's disease or one of
the root causes by targeting these
plumps of amyloid protein and
essentially it's been able to slow down
the progression of symptoms and we think
that that will give people longer with
more quality of life and give people
longer with their families who will it
help
so crucially and this is very important
this drug has been designed for people
with Alzheimer's disease because it
targets amyloid protein so unfortunately
it won't benefit people who are living
with other types of dementia for those
living with Alzheimer's disease this
drug is has been tested in people in the
early stages so that is the group of
people that we think it will benefit the
most and we think in 2025 it could
benefit at least 106 000 people in the
UK If it is approved
how much more work needs to be done
so in terms of next steps the drug needs
to be approved before it's available for
use this is still an experimental
medicine it's not available anywhere
else so we are waiting on the decisions
by regulatory bodies on whether the drug
will be approved for use or not uh in
terms of Europe those decisions uh we're
expecting in 2024 as the submission of
the data won't be until March 2023.
people have died on this though haven't
they on this um
look into what could possibly be not a
cure for Alzheimer's but a slowing down
of it
so there are side effects that have been
acknowledged in terms of the lacanumab
trial
um but it's important to remember that
clinical trials are monitoring safety
information very closely and safety is a
Paramount importance in clinical trials
and the data that's been collected on
safety will be going to those little
regulatory bodies that I mentioned and
they will be scrutinizing the data to
see if the drug is effective and also to
see if the drug is safe and they'll make
a decision based on that evidence and
essentially no drug will be approved if
it's not safe and it's not effective
will it be available on the NHS
it's too soon to know whether or not it
will be available we don't know whether
the drug will be approved in Europe yet
and once the drug is approved for use in
Europe and in the UK there will then be
applications made to nice about whether
or not it would be available on the NHS
of course we want the drugs to be
available to anyone that it will benefit
um but we don't know yet how that will
happen as this is unprecedented we've
never had a drug that is targeting the
root cause of Alzheimer's disease in
this way